[موسيقى]
مليون و400 الف برميل يوميا ووزير الطاقه
السعوديه يعتبره قرارا غير مسبوق
على واقع التوتر المتزايد يحضر بكير من
تصرفات غير مسؤوله في مضيق
[موسيقى]
عوده للشبكات العنيفه الى شوارع الخرطوم
ودارفور تستغيف بسبب تصاعد المواجهات
[موسيقى]
اختراق طبي مبشر علماء يعيدون توظيف خلايا
المعده لاطلاق الانسولين وعلاج مرض السكري
[موسيقى]
وفي تفاصيل التاسعه هذا المساء اعلن تحالف
اوبك بلس عن تخفيض جديد لانتاج النفط
بدايه من عام 20 24 وبحسب البيانات
الصادره عن التحالف مستوى الانتاج الجديد
سيكون عن 40.46 مليون برميل يوميا بدايه
من عام 20-24 وحتى نهايه ديسمبر 2020 من
جهه اكد مسؤولا بوزاره الطاقه السعوديه ان
المملكه ستخفض انتاج النفط طوعيا بخمس مئه
الف برميل لنهايه 20 24 كما اشار وزير
الطاقه الروسي لان موسكو ستمدد ايضا
تخفيضات الطوعيه بخمس مئه الف برميل كما
اعلنت الامارات والكويت وسلطنه عمان
والعراق والجزائر عن تخفيضات طوعيه ايضا
حتى نهايه العام المقبل
الاتفاق الذي توصلنا اليه اليوم غير مسبوق
سنكلف جهات مستقله بالتحقق من قدره
الانتاج لكل دوله خفض الانتاج يهدف الى
الحفاظ على استقرار السوق والامن انه يوم
عظيم بالنسبه لنا نحن مستمرون في ضرب
المثل فيما يتعلق بالشفافيه بخصوص تحقيق
الاولويات المهمه نوعيه التعاون غير مسبوق
وللمزيد حول قرار ينضم الينا مباشره من
رياض دكتور فهد بن جمعه خبير في شؤون
الطاقه دكتور فهد مرحبا بك معنا في
التاسعه هذا المساء ابدا معك اولا لماذا
وصف الاتفاق بغير المسبوق من قبل وزير
الطاقه السعودي اولا
اهلا وسهلا ومساء الخير عليك وعلى جميع
المشاهدين الكرام لانه اتفاق تاريخي جميع
الاعضاء او المنتجين متفقين ليس فقط على
التخفيض الالزامي بل تمديد التخفيض الطوعي
وهذا يدل على ان هناك انسجام وتوافق بين
اعضاء
للمحافظه على استقرار وتوازن الاسواق
النفط
نعم طيب دكتور فهد حتى نضع المشاهدين
بالصوره لانه الجميع مهتم حقيقه في قرارات
ولما تنعكس عليه هذه القرارات من اسعار
النفط وايضا حتى الاقتصاد العالمي بشكل
عام لما يمر في ما هي ابرز القرارات التي
تم اتخاذها اليوم
هو تمديد
الخفض الانتاجي الاسلامي وتمديد
التطوعي او الطوعي الى عام 24 نهايه عشرين
اربعه وعشرين وايضا المملكه العربيه
السعوديه سوف تضيف مليون برميل خف في
جولاي هذا كله يؤدي الى استقرار الاسواق
مؤمن الطاقه يعني تصوري لو لم يكن هناك
اتفاق مثل هذا الاتفاق كيف يتم الاستثمار
في انتاج المزيد من النفط كيف يتم
المحافظه على استقرار العرض والطلب وتوازن
الاسعار عندما يكون هناك الشح في المعروف
ماذا سيحدث سوف يكون هناك قفزه حاده في
اسعار النفط وسوف يتضرر المستهلك وسوف
يتضرر الاقتصاد العالمي وتكون هناك كارثه
لذا دول الاوبك بلس تسعى الى تحقيق الاه
اقتصاديه بعيدا عن الابعاد السياسيه من
اجل من اجل الاسواق ومن اجل استمرار
امدادات الطاقه
طيب دكتور فهد اسمح لي اتمنى ان تبقى معنا
في سياق هذه التغطيه المباشره حول هذه
القرارات قرارات نذهب الان الى الخبر
ومعنا فيصل الفائق مستشار في شؤون الطاقه
استاذ فيصل اهلا بك معنا في التاسعه هذا
المساء ما اهميه التخفيضات التوعيه حتى
نهايه هذا العام لكي نفهم كيف ستنعكس
علينا
كما ذكر اسمه وزير الطاقه بن سلمان يعني
هذا تعزيز الاستقرار اسواق النفط يعني
وضعت خارطه الطريق واضحه جدا لاستقرار
اسواق النفط الى نهايه عام 2020 بغض النظر
عن كل ما سمعناه من الاعلام النفطي الغربي
عن هناك توتر في العلاقه السعوديه الروسيه
مجره سياسات الانتاج على العكس تماما
للسنه السابعه على التوالي منتجي تحالف
اوبك بلاستي تتكلمي على نحو 40 مليون
برميل يوميا اظهروا توافق مقاطعه النظير
في اهلك الظروف لماذا احلك الظروف تم
اسواق النفط خصوصا مع مطلع النصف الثاني
لهذا العام بضبابيه عاليه جدا بحاله مع
عدم اليقين والافضل من ذلك ايضا انه
لم تنجرف خلف
الزياده في سقف الدين الامريكي وما وما
لها من بعض المعنويات الايجابيه الوقتيه
التي سوف تضع هناك زخم سعودي الاسعار
بالعكس كان نظره والتحالف عن يكون رؤيه
ثاقبه
للمدى المتوسط والمدى الطويل لانه هذا
الاستقرار في الاسواق سوف يعزز ايضا
استثمارات المنبع التي رايناها بعد
الجائحه هناك كثير تراجع كبير في
استثمارات المنبع مما سوف يهدد في امدادات
الطاقه العالميه ايضا
وضعت في العين انها لن تنجرف ايضا خلف
الانتفاش الانكماش الاقتصادي الصيني وبذلك
كان هناك ترقب وحذر شديد ايضا عندما ذكروا
الشفافيه في كذا موقف وفي كذا جواب على
الاسئله المهم جدا انه اظهرت شفافيه كبيره
في البيانات على العكس من وكات الطاقه
الدوليه والمنظمات الاخرى في بيانات
ودراسات متناقضه ومتضاربه بالعكس يكون
عليها اثر سلبي كبير جدا على استماره
المنبع وعلى مستقبل امن الطاقه العالمي
الشفافيه واضحه جدا يعني حتى عندما ذكروا
وكل هؤلاء سوف يكون لهم مصادر ثانويه في
تقييم معلومات وبيانات الانتاج لدول اوبك
ودول خارج
وانط هذه المعطيات التي يتحدث عنها استاذ
فيصل دكتور فهد اعود اليك مما جاء من
قرارات في
اجتماعاتنا اليوم كيف يمكننا ان نتصور
تفاعلات اسعار النفط مثلا يوم غد
نتوقع ان يكون هناك رده فعل ايجابيه
وسوف تعيد الاسعار الى مستواها التوازني
هناك اسعار
توازنيه عندما يكون هناك الفجوه بين العرض
والطلب ضيقه جدا وهذه الاسعار هنا نتطلع
الى سعر 80 دولار على الاقل لان الاسعار
منذ بدايه العام وهي تشهد انخفاض وتقلبات
وهناك مضاربه شرسه في اسواق النفط فمن
المتوقع ان تكون الرد رده الفعل غدا
ايجابيه وهذا يشجع الدول على المزيد من
الاستثمارات والمحافظه على الطاقات
الانتاجيه على المدى المتوسط والطويل انا
اشكركم جزيل الشكر كان معنا من الرياض
دكتور فهد بن جمعه خبير في شؤون الطاقه
واشكر ايضا من الخبر الاستاذ فيصل فايق
مستشار في شؤون الطاقه ايضا شكرا لكما
وخلال المؤتمر الصحفي الذي تلا اجتماع
اوبك بلس اكد الامير عبد العزيز بن سلمان
وزير الطاقه السعوديه ان القرار الاخير
يهدف لحمايه الاسواق من التذبذبات الحاده
ان كان صعودا او نزولا مؤكدا دور المنظمه
في تامين الاستقرار الاسواق
يساعد على يعني تعزيز فرص استقرار الاسواق
ومنعه من التذبذب الحاد والتذبذب الحاد
ياخذ الناحيتين نشف فقط الى الاسفل ولكن
ايضا الى الاعلى نعتقد ان هذه الاجراءات
هي الاجراءات اللي يجب ان نتصرف اننا
ناخذها كمنتجين مسؤولين عن
مره اخرى نريد ان نثبت العالم اننا نعمل
كبنوك مركزيه فعليه ناضجه تملك الادوات
والوسائل اللي تعزز من انها تمارس هذا
الدور
بفاعليه وبمهنيه
وقادره على انها تحقق هذا الاستقرار
المطلوب
[موسيقى]
اي مواجهه بيننا وامريكا ستكون كارثه على
العالم هكذا تقول الصين والجميع يصدق حتما
لكن ايا من الطرفين لا يسعى لهذه الحرب
ظاهريا على الاقل وزير الدفاع الصيني وبعد
مصافحه بارده مع نظيره الامريكي خلال
مؤتمر حول الانف سنغافوره اكد ان بلاده
تسعى للحوار وليس المواجهه ليرمي
المسؤوليه فيها كذا حرب لو اندلعت على
امريكا فالوزير الصيني المتربع على عرش
ثالث اقوى جيش في العالم قال ان مسؤوليه
اي توتر تقع على الدول التي تنشر قواعدها
العسكريه وتعزز سباق التصلح في المنطقه
وحذرا واشنطن من عوده عقليه الحرب البارده
التي تزكي المخاطر الامنيه طبعا وزير
الدفاع الصيني لا يمكن ان يطرح هكذا موضوع
دون الحديث عن تايوان ليؤكد مجددا بانها
شان داخلي للصين وان بعض الدول تتدخل فيه
بسوء نيه
وزير الدفاع الصيني الذي استخدم التلميح
في تحذيراته اكد ان زوبعه صراعات قادمه
بسبب المساعي لاقامه تحالفات عسكريه شبيهه
بحلف النيتو في منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ
فمن وجهه نظر بكين هذه المحاولات وسيله
لاختطاف في دول المنطقه وتضخيم الصراعات
والمواجهات الامر الذي لن يؤدي سوى الى
اغراق منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ في زوبعه
من النزاعات والصراعات ولكي ياخذ الجميع
تحضيرات على محمل الجد ذكر الوزير الصيني
الجميل بكوارث الحربين العالميتين الاولى
والثانيه
[موسيقى]
وبالتزامن مع التحذير الصيني من تشكيل
تحالفات في اسيا شبيهه اعلن وزير دفاع
الالماني ان برلين ستنشر مدمرتين بحريتين
في منطقه المحيطين الهادئ الهندي وذلك في
العام المقبل مشددا على ان الامر ليس
موجها ضد الصين ودعا الوزير الالماني دول
منطقه المحيطين الى اتخاذ موقف واضح ضد اي
هجمات موجهه ضد الهيكل الامن الدولي مثل
الحرب باوكرانيا
التوتر الامريكي الصيني المتزايد يدفعنا
الى التساول حول امكانيه بكين العسكريه
البحريه منها خاصه في حال اندلاع حرب مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اصول السفن
الحربيه الصينيه يتطور بشكل متسارع ما
يشكل ازمه متناميه للولايات المتحده التي
تبحث كافه الطرق بمواكبه ذلك فالبحريه
الصينيه هي الاكبر في العالم وتفوقها
وتفوقها العدد على الولايات المتحده يتسع
حتى ان قائد البحريه الامريكيه حذر مؤخرا
من انهم لا يستطيعون مواكبه التسارع
الصيني التقديرات العسكريه تقول ان الصين
قادره على بناء ثلاث سفن حربيه في الوقت
الذي تستغرقه الولايات المتحده لبناء
واحده عدديا وبحسب تقديرات بانتاجون تمتلك
البحريه الصينيه حوالي
340 سفينه حربيه بينما تمتلك الولايات
المتحده اقل من 300 سفينه الدفاع
الامريكيه تعتقد ان الاسطول الصيني سينمو
الى 400 في المقبلين بينما سيستغرق الاصول
الامريكي حتى عام 2045 ليصل الى 350 سفينه
حربيه المخاوف الامريكيه لا تقتصر على
التفوق العدد المتزايد للبحريه الصينيه بل
على حقيقه مفادها ان بعض السفن التي
تنتجها الصين لديها قوه نيران اكبر من بعض
نظراتها الامريكيه فالمدمره
55 هنا نتحدث عن مدمره ناتشانكس 055 صينيه
والتي يصنفها البعض كواحده من اقوى
المدمرات في العالم تزنوا
0550 بابين اثني عشر الفا الى 13 الف طن
وهي اكبر من المدمرات النموذجيه واقرب في
الحجم الى فئه الطرادات تايكون ديروغا
تابعه للبحريه الامريكيه تمتلك 122 خليه
لنظام الاطلاق العمودي فباستطاعه اطلاق
صواريخ ارض جو وصواريخ مضاده للسفن بينما
احدث مدمر التحريره الامريكيه من فئه علب
الركبه وهي تمتلك 96 خليه لنظام الاطلاق
العمودي تعمل الصين على تضخيم اصولها من
هذه المدمرات حيث بدات في بناء هذا الطراز
عام 2014 واطلقت مؤخرا نسختها الثامنه
شيان
وبالحديث عن مدمرات لا تقتصر صناعتها او
ملكيتها على الولايات المتحده والصين فقط
بل ان بعض الدول تنافسها في الجوده
لنستعرض معكم اهم هذه المدمرات اولا مدمره
سيجونج
الكوريه الجنوبيه هي شبيهه بطراز نان
تشانك 55 الصينيه
حوالي 10 الى 12 الف طن هي اصغر قليلا من
شبهتها الصينيه لكنها تتفوق عليها بقوه
النيران مع 128 خليه واسلحه تشمل صواريخ
ارض جو مضاده للغواصات وصواريخ ايضا كروز
ايضا لدينا مدمره مايا الي وهي احدى افضل
المدمرات عالميا مسلحه بسته وتسعين خليه
في ال اس ويمكنها اطلاق كل صواريخ المضاده
للصواريخ البالسيه والصواريخ المضاده
للغواصات تمتلك ايضا اجهزه استشعار وانظمه
خاصه متطوره جدا ولدي القدره على تدمير
الصواريخ الباليستيه التي تنتقل خارج
الغلاف الجوي للارض مدمره يابانيه اخرى
وهي مدمره موغامي هي سفينه حربيه سريعه
تزن
5500 طن مع سته عشره خليه وتطلق بال
الصواريخ ارض جو ايضا صواريخ مضاده للسفن
ما قلته في الاسابيع الماضيه وخاصه في
اليومين الماضيين لقد عبرت عن قلقي بشان
السلوك غير المسؤول الذي رايناه مع عمليات
الاعتراض القريبه وبينما كنا قادمين رايت
مثالا على احدى طائراتنا التي اعترضتها
احدى طائراتهم على مسافه خطيره للغايه وفي
اليوم الاخير فقط راينا حادثه اخرى حيث
عبرت احدى سفنهم امام احدى سفننا ربما
تكون هناك 150 قدما او شيء من هذا القبيل
وهذا امر خطير للغايه
على كل حال نذهب الى ضيفي التاسعه هذا
المساء الكريمين معي هنا في الاستوديو
الهام لي الصحه في الصيني ومن واشنطن طارق
الشامي الكاتب والمحلل السياسي مرحبا بكما
معنا في التاسعه هذا المساء سيد الهام
اهلا بك اولا امريكا تتهم الصين اذا
بتصرفات غير مسؤوله وهنا نسال ما الذي
يدفع الصين كقوه اقتصاديه كبيره انت تستفز
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه عسكريا هذه
المره نعم عندما نتكلم عن الاعمال
الاستفزازيه من الافضل الجانب الامريكي
يعني كل سفن الحربيه الصينيه بجوار الصين
ولكن هناك الكثير من حاملات الطيران
والسفن حربيه الامريكيه بجوار الصين في
بحر الصين الجنوبي وهناك دائما طائرات
المراقبه يطير
باجواء بجانب
الجو الصيني وبالاضافه الى ذلك يعني عندما
نتكلم عن ما يسمى بسباقه تسلح بين الصين
والولايات المتحده هذا موضوع مهم
ولكن سانقل فكرتك الى استاذ طارق استاذ
طارق سمعت استاذ الهام ما يقول اذا اردنا
ان نتحدث عن الاستفزاز واشنطن هي من بدات
بهذا الامر كما يعتبر السيد الهام فيما
يتعلق بقواعد عسكريه وايضا طائرات قريبه
من الصين هل تريد فعلا
لا اعتقد ان واشنطن تريد الحرب وهذا ما
قاله ايضا وزير الدفاع الامريكي اوستن في
اكثر من مناسبه واكثر من مسؤول قال ذلك
لكن وجود الطائرات او السفن الحربيه
الامريكيه او غيرها من الادوات العسكريه
في المياه هي المياه الدوليه وهي لتعزيز
تحالف
الامريكي في شرق اسيا هناك اتفاقات دفاع
مشتركه مع كوريا الجنوبيه مع اليابان هناك
ايضا نظره امريكيه بان التوجهات القصريه
الصينيه سواء كانت بخصوص تايوان او بخصوص
بحر الصين الجنوبي هي في غايه الخطوره وهي
تناقض القانون البحري الدولي وكانت هناك
ايضا يعني
محكمه دوليه قالت
بتتعلق باتفاقيه البحريه الدوليه قالت في
عام يعني 82 تقريبا بان الولايات ان الصين
بالفعل يعني تحدد مناطق بحريه وتضعها في
اطار انها خاضعه لها نيرفوذها البحري في
حين ان ذلك ليس من حقها وهذا ما يثير غضب
الولايات المتحده التي تنظر الى اعتبارات
استراتيجيه اخرى تتعلق بالتجاره الدوليه
وحريه الشحن الدولي فيها هذا امام تبادل
الاتهامات بين البلدين سيد الهام عندما
ينظر اليوم الى تصلح وسباق التسلح من
المنظور الصيني وخصوصا التفوق العددي اقله
في البحر هل الصين تحمل في سباق التصلح
هذا بعد عسكري او مجرد رسائل سياسيه
للعالم وابرزها الى الولايات المتحده اول
شيء لدى كل دوله حاجه لدفاع النفس وخصوصا
امام هذه الاعمال الاستفزازيه عندما نتكلم
الصين ان نتكلم مع ان القوات البحريه
الصينيه طبعا عدد سفن تتفوق على الولايات
المتحده لكن هناك مصطلح مهم جدا حموله
الاجماليه لصفن الحربيه للقوات البح في
الحقيقه القوات البحريه الامريكيه الحموله
الاجماليه لسفن الحربيه تقريبا نفس الشيء
لكل القوات البحريه لدول غير امريكا لذلك
هناك فتوى كبيره بين القوات البحريه
الصينيه والامريكيه وثاني شيء نتكلم مع
احداث القوات البحريه الصينيه
الامريكيه ففي الحقيقه حاملات الطيران
والطائرات
اهدافها او اغراضها لتحقيق على الهيمنه في
العالم باكمله ولكن عندما تكلم عن سفن
الحربيه الصينيه نحن الان في
جيبوتي هناك قاعد شبه لقاعده العسكريه فقط
للقوات البحريه الصينيه ولكن كم عدد
قواعد القوات مهما كانت الجويه او البحريه
في منطقه الشرق الاوسط فقط لذلك يعني
احداث القوات العسكريه الصينيه لحمايه عن
نفسه وحمايه القياده والاعراض وخاصه عندما
نتكلم عن قضيه تايوان في الحقيقه قبل قليل
يعني سمعنا الضيفنا هناك نقطه مهمه جدا
يعني لتحقيق مصالح المشتركه بين الولايات
المتحده وحلفائه في منطقه اسيا فيك ولكن
عندما نلجا الى الخريطه كم المسافه بين
يابان وكوريا الجنوبيه وبحر الصين الجنوبي
هذا امر مهم جدا وفي النفس الوقت عندما
نتكلم عن دوله الاسيان دوله اسيان في
الحقيقه هناك كثير من الدول في هذه
المنطقه لا تعتذر انفسهم من حلفاء
الولايات المتكده لكن لا تمتعده تعتبر كل
هذه الدوله حلفاء الله هذا التناقد واضح
بالنسبه لسياسات الخارجيه والسياسات
الدفاع الولايات يعني استاذ طارق سمعت
مقاله استاذ الهام هل تغامر الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه باي تحركات خصوصا في
المحاطين الهندي والهادئ لجر ربما مواجهه
عسكريه
معها الصين
يعني لا اعتقد انه الولايات المتحده تريد
ذلك بدليل ان يعني هي من الناحيه التجاريه
والاقتصاديه التعاون التجاري
والتجاره مع الصين لن تتاثر خلال العام
الماضي وفقا للارقام الصادره من الجانبين
بل زادت وهذا يعني ان هناك تعاون على
الرغم ان هذه التوترات السياسيه والعسكريه
لكن في ذات الوقت واضح جدا من التقارير
الاستخباراتيه ومن التصريحات المسؤولين
الدفاعيين والاستخباراتيين في الولايات
المتحده هو انهم ينظرون بكثير من القلق
للسلوك الصيني سواء ما يتعلق بتايوان التي
تشهد انتخابات في يناير المقبل والصين
متوتره قليلا لانها تخشى من فوز الحزب
التقدمي الديمقراطي وهو يعني حزب الذي
يحكم الان وهو ايضا لا يريد يعني تعضيض
العلاقات مع الصين هي تشعر بالتوتر في هذا
لكن في في ذات الوقت هي الولايات المتحده
لديها مصالح استراتيجيه كقوه عالميه تريد
ان تحافظ على قوتها وعلى مصالحها
الاستراتيجيه سواء مع دول الاسيا او مع
كوريا الجنوبيه او غيرها او حتى في
الفلبين التي منحتها عددا من القواعد
العسكريه ثمانيه قواعد عسكريه مؤخرا حتى
يمكن ان ترسخ اقدامها
وتتحدى المطامع الصينيه حسب ما ترى واشنطن
في هذا الصدد هي ترى ان هناك تجاره تصل
الى يعني تقريبا 30% من تجاره العالم تمر
من بحر الصين الجنوبي هناك ايضا يعني
كميات ضخمه جدا من الغاز الطبيعي
كذلك
ولكن الحديث تتم دائما ولكن انتهى الوقت
شكرا جزيلا لك من واشنطن طارق الشامل
الكاتب المحل السياسي واشكر ضيفي هنا في
الاستوديو الهام لي الصح الفلسطينيه شكرا
لكما
بدات اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه اليوم اول
محادثات وزاريه دفاعيه بينهما منذ اكثر من
ثلاث سنوات وذلك خلال وجودهم في سنغافوره
في اشاره الى تحسين العلاقات الثنائيه وسط
تهديد الذي يمثله برامج تطوير الصواريخ
النوويه في كوريا الشماليه
[موسيقى]
تاسع هذا المساء مستمره ونتابع في سياقها
ولكن بعد قليل
حرب ترامب وديسانس تضعه مصداقيه
الجمهوريين على المحك
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في التاسعه هذا المساء وفي
تفاصيلها ايضا نزاع السودان يدخل اسبوعه
الثامن وافق التهدئه مسدوده حتى اللحظه
عدد الضحايا ارتفع والحاجه ماسه الى
المساعدات الانسانيه اذا ما ذهبنا معكم
الى الاشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني وحتى
قوات الدعم السريع استمرت في عده مناطق
بالعاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم وخصوصا مع
تركزها شمالي مدينه الخرطوم بحري عند هذه
النقطه كما نتابع طبعا تلك هذه الشبكات
تزاملت مع قصف جوي هذا القصف الجوي نفذه
سلاح الجو السوداني مصحوبا ايضا بقصف
مدفعي خصوصا على قاعده كرري الموجوده في
هذه المنطقه حيث اعلنت قوات الدعم السريع
السودانيه اسقاط طائره حربيه هذه الطائره
من طراز ميج في منطقه بحري بالتحديد عند
هذه النقطه طبعا مع احتدام الاشتباك اكثر
فاكثر في هذه المناطق وعوده الطائرات
المقاتله في سماء الخرطوم كانت دعت
السعوديه والولايات المتحده الامريكيه دعت
طرفين لاتفاق على وقف جديد لاطلاق نار
وتنفيذي بشكل فعال بهدف وقف دائم للعمليات
العسكريه فوزاره الخارجيه السعوديه في
الرياض وان اعلنت ان واشنطن والرياض
حريصتان على استمرار المحادثات مع وفدي
الجيش والدعم السريع
[موسيقى]
دارفور منطقه منكوبه فبعد ان تجددت
للشبكات بين الجيش ودعم السريع لاسيما في
مدينه كتم بولايه شمال الاقليم فالقوات
المسلحه قالت ان كل ما تردد عن سقوط كتب
في ايدي دعم السريع عار عن الصحه عدد
القتل في المدينه التي تبعد 65 كيلومترا
شمالا ارتفع الى 40 جلهم من المدنيين حاكم
دارفور اعلن الاقليم منطقه منكوبه مع
استمرار اعمال النهب والقتل قائلا ان
المدنيين في مدينتينا يتعرضون لانتهاكات
فظيعه
[موسيقى]
الشبكات متواصله في محيط بخمت على الرغم
من تراجع حده المعارك بشكل كبير في
المدينه التي سيطرت عليها القوات الروسيه
فهيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه قالت ان القوات
الروسيه نفذت هجومين فاشلين حول بخمه وشنت
ايضا عددا من الغارات الجويه والقصف
المدفعي تحديدا على القرى المجاوره اذا ما
تحدثنا عن بخموت عند هذه النقطه قائد
القوات البريه الاوكرانيه
تواصل عملياتها هناك مؤكدا ثقته بتحقيق
الانتصار في منطقه بخموت في بحيط بالتحديد
اما اذا انتقلنا معكم في الخارطه الى
دانيبروبي التحديد وعند هذه النقطه فقالت
اوكرانيا ان طفله في الثانيه من العمر
قتلت في هذه المنطقه وايضا جرح اثنان
وعشرون شخصا جراء الاشتباكات التي حصلت في
هذه المنطقه وايضا الاستهداف الهجوم الجو
تحديدا الذي طال منطقه دانيبرو وسط البلاد
الرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي فقال في تغريده له هاجم
الروس المدينه اصاموا بمبنيين سكنيين من
طابقين لسوء الحظ ان هناك اناس تحت
الانقاض كما قال
في تغريدته الاخيره اما اذا انتقلنا معكم
الى الجانب الاخر من الحدود وتحديدا في
منطقه حيث ادت ايضا قبائف اوكرانيه هذه
القذائف ادت الى مقتل شخصين في منطقه
بالتحديد كما ذكر حاكم المنطقه في
بيلجورود هناك اذا كثافه الضربات الجويه
الروسيه على اوكرانيا وايضا القصف الجوي
على اراضي روسيه كانت تصاعدت بشكل كبير
اذا ما تابعنا معكم التطورات الميدانيه
خصوصا في الاسابيع الاخيره فانما تؤكد كيف
انها تستعد لهجوم كبير ضد قوات موسكو بهدف
سعاده الاراضي كانت خسرتها منذ العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه في فبراير 2022
[موسيقى]
خارطه المعارك في اوكرانيا بدات تتسع
رقعتها وباتت المسيرات العنوان البارز لاي
هجوم يتم الحديث عنه وهي استراتيجيه جديده
تتبناها اوكرانيا وحتى روسيا لتحقيق مكاسب
في الميدان
حرب المسيرات استراتيجيه جديده تتماشى مع
جغرافيا المواقع في الصراع الدائري على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه الدبابات على الارض
والطائرات بدون طيار في كل من المجال
الجوي الروسي والاوكراني المسيرات
المتفجره باتت سلاحا اساسيا في المعركه
فكل من الجانب الروسي والاوكراني يحاول في
الفتره الاخيره تكثيف الهجمات المضاده
بالطائرات المسيره التي وصلت الى عاصمتي
البلدين موسكو
تقييم حديث اجره معهد رويال اليونايتد
للخدمه البحثيه قدر ان اوكرانيا تخسر
حوالي عشره الاف مسيره كل شهر حيث ان ابرز
المسيرات التي اعتمدت عليها اوكرانيا منذ
بدايه الحرب شملت مسيرات بيرقدار التركيه
ومسيلات سويتش بليده الامريكيه الى جانب
طائرات مايفيكا الرباعيه الصينيه
والطائرات ذات الاستخدام الواحد
الحصيله في الميدان دفعت اوكرانيا لانتاج
اعداد كبيره من المسيرات لسد النقص وعلى
هذا الاساس وجه التكييف قدراتها للحصول
على هذا السلاح باكبر كميه ممكنه هذا الكم
الضخم سيتم انتاجه محليا حيث ان 30 شركه
محليه ستكلف بانتاج مسيرات قادره على حمل
رؤوس حربيه وتتميز بالدقه في تحديد
المواقع وطائره خروش الانتحاريه هي واحده
من عشرات الطائرات القتاليه بدون طيار
التي تم تطويرها محليا والتي صممت لتكون
ارخص واكثر دقه من الاسلحه بعيده المدى
التقليديه المتوفره حاليا ويمكن لمشغليها
اما اختيار الرؤوس الحربيه الحراريه
لتدمير قواعد العدو او الطلقات المضاده
للدبابات التي تسمح بتدمير اهداف روسيه في
عمق الجبهات الاماميه شديده التح المسيره
يمكن تزويدها براس حربي يصل وزنه الى
ثلاثه كيلوغرامات مما يعني ان حمولتها
تبلغ خمسه اضعاف حموله الطائرات
الانتحاريه سويتش بليد التي تبرعت بها
الولايات المتحده في الاونه الاخيره
تستخدم كياف المسيرات بشكل عملياتي افضل
بقصفها مواقع تؤثر على لوجيسيات الجيش
الروسي وبالتالي سيكون الرهان على من له
قدرات دفاعيه اكبر وانظمه رادار احدث لوقف
مواجهات الدرونز
[موسيقى]
مخاوف جمهوريه من تصاعد الهجمات بين
ترامبوا وديسانتس تدفع استراتيجي الحزب
لتحذير من خطوره هذه الحرب على مصداقيه
الجمهوريين السباق التمهيدي الانتخابات
الرئاسيه الامريكيه في الحزب الجمهوري
تحول الى مواجهه مريره بين المرشحين الذين
يحتلان المرتبه الاولى والثانيه في
استطلاعات الراي فالاستطلاع يرجح حصول دون
الترامب على 49% من نوايا تصويت ورونديس
على 19% رغم ان تصويت الجمهوريين ما زال
يبعد اكثر من سته اشهر
ملامحها في فعاليات انتخابيه في ولايتي
ايوا ونيو فحمله ديسانتس اي حاكم ولايه
فلوريدا كانت ركزت على تصويره مدافعا شرسا
عن القيم الجمهوريه المحافظه في قضايا
تشمل اجهاض والهجره والانفاق الحكومي حتى
الجريمه ويحمل المرشح الذي يبلغ اربعه
واربع عاما يحمل ترامب مسؤوليه تتراجع
اجنده المحافظين خاصه خلال السنوات
الاربعه التي قضاها في البيت الابيض في
المقابل يرد ترامب ومساعدوها على تلك
الاتهامات بالقول ان ديسانتس يحتاج الى
اكثر من ثمان سنوات لانجاز ما حققه ترامب
مقللين من انجازاته بصفته حاكمه لفلوريدا
حرس ديسانس قبل اسابيع من اعلان الترشحه
رسميا حرص على تفادي انتقاد ترامب
والانخراط في الهجمات الشخصيه مقدما نفسه
ثقلا موازنا ورصينا وموضوعيا لرئيس السابق
[موسيقى]
وهي
نذهب الى واشنطن ومعنا من هناك بير غانم
مراسل العربيه اهلا بك معنا في التاسعه
هذا المساء كر ترامب كان حذر ديسانتوس في
السابق ترشحك يعني انقسام الحزب الجمهوري
هل هذه حقيقه وواقعه اليوم
ما زال المسيطر والمتقدم وربما سيكون من
الصعب على اي مرشح اخر ان يقسم الحزب
وياخذ من شعبيه ترامب طبعا لا يريد ترامب
ان يكون هناك منافسون وان يبقى هو
الزعيم الاوحد بدون اي تحد من قبل مرشحين
اخرين ولكن كما ذكرتي قبل قليل
ديسنتس وشخصيات اخرى مثل البانس
ونكههيلي وغيرهم يريدون القول ان ترامب لا
يمثل
حزب الجمهوري التقليدي المحافظ وعلى
الناخبين الجمهوريين ان يروا ان لديهم
خيارات اخرى في هذه الحمله الانتخابيه كيف
ينظر مراقبون الى رؤيه ديسانتس هل هي
مقنعه للناخبين
كثيرا بمعنى ان قدم ديسانتس نفسه على انه
حاكم ولايه كبيره جمهوري استطاع ان يواجه
الكثير من الحملات من قبل الليبراليين مثل
شركه ديزني
استطاع ان يواجه ايضا الكثير من
الديمقراطيين الليبراليين في ولايه
فلوريدا حول قضايا التربيه وحول قضايا
الصرف ومثل بنجاح كبير القيم الجمهوريه
المحافظه وبالتالي يرى الكثيرون ان لديه
حظوظ عاليه ولكن يجب القول ايضا انه اعلن
ترشيحه وكان من المنتظر انه منذ ان اعلن
ترشيحه واي منذ عشره ايام تقريبا ان ترتفع
شعبيه هذا الرجل لدى الناخبين الجمهوريين
لكنها لم ترتفع الشعبيه التي ارتفعت هي
شعبيه ترامب
يعني هل نفهم بان ان انقسام الجمهوريين
اليوم هو انقسام طبيعي
وخلافات طبيعيه سيتم تجاوزها وسيبقى
المرشح الاوحد
وفي التاسعه ايضا تتابعون بعض قليل
هاري اول فرد في الاسره الحاكمه يمثل امام
القضاء منذ عام 1891
وفي التاسعه هذا المساء نتابع في سياقها
ايضا
[موسيقى]
بعد مسيره طويله فتى طريز المدلل خارج
اسوار سانتياغو برنابيو
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في التاسع وفي تفاصيلها ايضا
تطور طبي مبشر في مساعي الحد من مرض
السكري وعلاجه بعد ان تمكن علماء من
اختراق الخلايا البشريه التي تنتج
الانسولين العلماء توصلوا بفضل ذلك الى
عكس مرض السكري لدى الفئران وفق دراسه
حديثه نشرتها مجله
فالعلماء اعادوا توظيف خلايا المعده
البشريه لاطلاق الانسولين ما مكن من اداره
مرض السكري من النوع الاول بشكل فعال كشفت
التجربه التي قادها بحيثون من وايلد في
الولايات المتحده ان عمليات زرع خلايا
افراز الانسولين في المعده عكست مرض
السكري في الفئران فهرمون الانسولين بالغ
الاهميه في تنظيم نسبه الجلوكوز في الدم
وعندما لا ينتجه الجسم بشكل كافي تكون
هناك مضاعفات خطيره اما الباحثون يعملون
ان يساعد البحث في دفع الجسم الى انتاج
الانسولين بشكل طبيعي مره اخرى لمرضى الذي
يعتبر واحدا من اسرع الامراض المزمنه
انتشارا على مستوى العالم وفقا لدراسه
اجريت في عام 2022
[موسيقى]
شكرا سيدتي على الاستضافه هذه الدراسه
اخذت عينات من خلايا المعده وفي الاساس
عند التكوين
الخلايا الجذعيه لخلايا المعده وخلايا
البنكرياس تتشابه جدا الى حد كبير لذلك
استطاعوا اخذ خلايا من المعده وحولوها
بطرق علميه وبالمختبر وقد شرحوا في
المقال العلمي كيف حولوها وكيف استعملوا
المواد حتى تحويلها الى خلايا تفرض
الانسولين واستطاعوا تحويلها الى هذه
الخلايا ثم زرعوها في المعدن مجددا واعطت
ما يسمى الجاي اناس يعني خلايا معده تفرض
الانسولين تشبه الخيال بكرسيه حتى 70% من
الشبه عند الفئران طبعا هذا هذا
بدات منذ سنوات
هو مريض ليس عنده انسولين لذا يجب ان يضع
انسولين ويجب ان يتحكم اما في هذه الطريقه
فقط زرعت له خلايا تفرز الانسولين طبيعيا
وتتعامل مع السكر في الدم كما لو لم يكن
معه مرض
سكريبت الدعم
انسولين
اذا قرات المقال ابتلينا انهم متفائلون
جدا بهذا الموضوع
اتامل ذلك طبعا ولكن هناك ابحاث كثيره
وسائل متعدده لزرع الانسولين او خلايا
البنكرياس حتى يتمكنوا من من الغاء المرض
حتى الان لم تكن ناجحه ولم تؤثر في تطور
هذا المرض ومازلنا نعالج بالطرق
العاديه
اييي حقن الانسولين او بالبومبي اللي
بنحطها هلا وهي تهين تسهل كثيرا حياه
المريض السكري طبعا
اليه فيما يتعلق بهذا العلاج وان فعلا راى
النور في المستقبل القريب هل يمكن الحديث
عنه بانه علاج يستطيع اي انسان ربما دفعه
هل هو علاج مكلف ام ماذا
اي انسان لا بده يكون طبعا الانسان معه
مرض السكري والمرض ليس مرض
ياتي عندها اي سؤال اذا كان
في البدايه سيكون
بالبدايه سيكون بالطبع مكلفا ولكن كلما
زاد استعماله كل ما خفت الكلفه كل ما زاد
انتاج هذه الخلايا بالمطلق ليس مكلفا
بمعنى ان زرعه ليس مكذبا بالنظور وحده
يمكن الزرع هذه الخلايا في المعده التي
ستفرز الانسولين هذا ما حدث مع الفئران
يعني لا يتطلب عمليه جراحيه او عمليه
استثنائيه ولكن كونها كونها طريقه حديثه
وجديده ومبتكره هنا الكلفه فيها ولكن مع
الوقت سيخف ستخف الكلفه وكل ما كثر عدد
المرضى الذين سيستعملونها بالطبع ستغف
الكلفه شكرا جزيلا لكم باريس دكتور ايلين
اقل كلفه من من علاج السكري اليوم
تمام شكرا جزيلا لك من باريس دكتور ايلي
حداد الاختصاصي في امراض السكري والغدد
الصماء
[موسيقى]
من المتوقع ان تشهد المحكمه العليا في
بريطانيا اسبوعا قضائيا حافلا مع عوده
الامير هاري الى العاصمه لتقديم افادته
ليكون بذلك اول فرد رفيع المستوى بالاسره
المالكه يقدم ادله امام محكمه منذ عام
1891 سيدلي هاري به افادته في قضيه ضد
مجموعه مرر للنشر على خلفيه مزاعم حول
استخدام المجموعه لمحققين واختراقها
لهاتفي للحصول على معلومات تم استخدامها
في الاخبار في وقت تصف فيه وسائل الاعلام
البريطانيه هذه المحاكمه بقضيه العصر
نذهب الى لندن ومعنى الكاتب الصحفي محمد
شباره اهلا بك استاذ محمد معنا في التاسعه
هذا المساء ماذا يمكن ان تتوقع من محاكمه
العصر في بريطانيا
يعني بشكل او باخر استاذه نادين مساء
الخير لك والمشاهدين الكرام ان هاري اليوم
يدخل الى المحكمه من بابها العريض ولكن لا
ندري اذا كان سيخرج منها سالما انها قضيه
اختبار اوليه لعرض امكانيه اعتماد هذه
الادله
والوثائق
والاخبار عن المنقوله والتي هناك ادله
حولها عن النهج الذي انتهجته هذه الصحف
لاختراق الهواتف وبالتالي اختراق خصوصيه
الافراد ان كانوا من المشاهير كما هي حاله
هذه القضيه التي تمثل مئه شخصيه مشهوره في
الحياه العامه الثقافه الفن وبالتالي هاري
اخذ على نفس قطعه عهد على نفسه انه سيواجه
الصحافه ولكن مواجهه الصحافه بهذا الشكل
القانوني وغير المسبوق ايضا لها يعني ربما
تشكل مخاطر عليه وبالتالي لا ندري كيف
ستنتهي طب هل يمكن ان يجر معه اشخاصا
اخرين خصوصا امام الاسئله الطويله
والاستجوابات
هذا هو مصدر الخطر على الامير هاري وايضا
على الملكيه البريطانيه لان في المحكمه
يعني ترتفع كل ترتفع كل الكلفه وكل
الامتيازات وهناك عليه ان يرد على الاسئله
بغض النظر
عن قوتها ومدى خصوصيتها ومدى دخولها في
تفاصيل حياته الخاصه وربما حياه مقربين
منه وهنا المشكله الكبيره التي يواجهها
هاري عاده استاذه نادين ما تتم تسويه مثل
قضايا التشهير التنصت التعاقب تعقب الهاتف
في حلول توصلت يعني ممكن ان نذكر
الناشر ناشر صحيفه الصن حوالي يعني تكلف
حتى العام الماضي حوالي مليار و200 مليون
جنيه استرليني حتى الان في قضايا تتعلق
باختراق الخصوصيه هنا وهناك على مدى
السنوات وكلفته ايضا اغلاق احدى الصحف
كبرى الصحف نيوز اوف عام 2011 وبالتالي
هذه قضيه مختلفه لانه هري لا يريد
التسويات ويريد ان يحاكم هذه الصحف وايضا
يكلفها التعويضات واكثر من ذلك ان تعتذر
على هذه التصرفات وان لا تقترف مثلها هناك
حوالي 130 حادثه يعني تنصت واختراق هواتف
من ضمن هذه القضيه المحكمه ستنظر بحوالي
اعتقد 10 منها وليس اكثر على صعيد
الاختبار لرؤيه اذا كان هناك للمحكمه
اختصاص وقدره على البث فيها انا اشك
رك جات
الصحه
خطه فرنسيه لاجلاء مهاجرين من باريس في
مساعد اخلاء العاصمه من حوالي 3600 شخص
بلا ماوى غالبيتهم من المهاجرين الخطه
الفارسيه تاتي في اطار استعدادات عاصمه
النور لاستقبال دوره الالعاب الاولمبيه في
صيف العام المقبل تقرير لغاردن قال ان
الحكومه الفرنسيه تزعم انها تسعى الى منح
المهاجرين حياه افضل عبر نقلهم الى اقاليم
اخرى في البلاد ترى صحيفه البريطانيه ان
المهاجرين يعنون الكثير من الصعوبات في
باريس ان ملاجئ الطوارئ مقتظه تعج بهم في
حين يقضي طالبوا لجوء ليال قاسيه في خيام
ضمن معسكرات اقيمت على الطريق دائري
وبالقرب من ملاعب رولان غاغوسا الشهيره
حيث تجري بطوله فرنسا المفتوحه للتنس اضحت
مدرسه ملاذ لذوحه 500 مهاجر معظمهم قدم من
افريقيا ونقلت صحيفه عن المنتقدين
اقتناعهم بان هدف رئيس الفرنسي الوحيد من
وراء الاجراءات الجديده هو اخفاء ازمه
الهجره عن الزوار الاجانب الذين سيحضرون
مناسبتي بطوله العالم للرجبي والعاب
الاولمبيه
[موسيقى]
اعلن ريال مدريد الاسباني رحيل النجم
الاسباني كريم بنزيما عن صفوف الفريق
وانهاء عقده بالتراضي قال نادي في بيان له
ان مسيره بنزيما كانت مثالا لاحترافيه وقد
استحق حق تقرير مستقبله ياتي هذا فيما
تشير انباء الى توصل نادي اتحاد جده
السعوديه لاتفاق مع بنزيما للعب في صفوفه
لمده موسمين
تاسع هذا المساء انتهت ونذكر بعنوانها
بواقع مليون و400 الف يوميا ووزير الطاقه
السعوديه يعتبره قرارا غير مسبوق
[موسيقى]
على وقع التوتر المتزايد يحضر بكين من
تصرفات غير مسؤوله في مضيق
عوده للشبكات العنيفه الى شوارع الخرطوم
ودارفور تستغيث بسبب تصاعد المواجهات
[موسيقى]
ويعرضون صفقه تبادل مع موسكو وحاكم
بالقرود ومستعد للتفاوض
اختراق طبي مبشر علماء يعيدون توظيف خلايا
المعده لاطلاق الانسولين وعلاج مرضى
السكري
هذا المكان انتهت ولكن اخبرنا بالتاكيد
مستمره فبعد قليل طاهر بركه و360 ساعه
اخباريه مختلفه معك يا طاهر يسعد هالمسا
ومساك ناديننا اهلا بالمشاهدين الكرام
سنتابع بكل تاكيد موضوع التطورات في
بيلجرود يبدو ان المعركه انتقلت في جانب
منها على الاقل الى عمق الاراضي الروسيه
ولو كانت الحدوديه نتحدث ايضا عن عوده
تصعيد الى الخرطوم ودرفور بشكل اساسي في
السودان وكذلك القرار غير المسبوق كما
اوصف سعوديا لاوببك بلس ونتحدث عن مهاجمه
بعض الاعلام الامريكي لرونديسانتس فارجو
ان تكوني معنا
شكرا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات